4e tour de la coupe de france ce
dimanche 29 septembre les rouges de
guyancourt recevez mitry mory au stade
maurice baquet en première période les
gluants courtois qui évolue en deuxième
division de district font jeu égal face
aux seine-et-marne et malgré les deux
divisions d'écart le score à la mi temps
à 0 à 0 donnez moi des 33 minutes monter
bien haut les a mis sous pression
enfin deux hommes étaient un peu
fatigués mais bon on a tenu
on a un gros groupe productif et même
dans les moments difficiles on est là
pour pour pour jouer pour pas prendre de
but les belles promesses entrevues lors
de la première période s'effondre
quelques minutes après le retour des
vestiaires du haut cours craque une
première fois sur cette action les saint
quentinois ne s'en relèveront pas le
concède quatre autres buts pour
s'incliner sur le score de 5 à 0 en
deuxième mi temps on a subi un petit peu
l'endroit on va dire du plus fort
tactiquement ils ont été meilleurs que
nous dans l'utilisation du ballon ils
ont été meilleurs que nous et nous
défensivement on a un petit peu chuté et
on a une équipe jeune c'est à dire avec
on a pris un but des buts n'a pas su
relever la tête et on a subi un peu a
subi le match en fait on n'a fait que
subir le match on n'a pas eu de révolte
on n'a pas eu la force nécessaire pour
aller chercher un résultat bien au
courant maintenant devoir se
reconcentrer sur le championnat de 2e
division de district pour atteindre son
objectif la montée les ivy m'occupe pour
l'instant la 6e place